can you tell us what the status of
raven's home is do i love
my cast yes is it my decision no
have you given more thought to possibly
revisiting your daytime tv roots what i
love
about this platform youtube we're able
to talk about
topics without influences of a daytime
producer saying okay i need you to have
this point of view and fight it your
former bandmate keeley williams
she was in the news last week she's
going to be part of this new series on
b-e-t
will you be tuning in no i'm good
raven simone miranda may day it is so
nice to see the two of you i can't help
but notice
these gorgeous coordinated looks that
are going on here
what inspired this we are filming a
little video
for our channel and our new youtube
channel and um
basically christmas in may felt
appropriate giving us
holiday realness in may i'm absolutely
here for it
the idea of well we should start a
youtube channel
why did you decide to do this and why
was now the right time so we're a unique
couple you know we're a married lesbian
biracial biracial couple and there
aren't many people
out there showcasing what that
relationship looks like
and we're also pretty funny and people
already
love raven and it just felt like this
great time it just to do it can you kind
of describe
like your content creation process who
comes up with the ideas for videos and
and what has it been like filming
together
it's a joint effort for sure i've had
uh you know in the middle of the nine
days we should do this video
she's meticulously writing down looking
through other youtubes and be like
that's a trend let's see if we can go
here she comes up with the contents
most of the time i'm the editor and the
camera person i have a director slash
actress over here so i will do something
and she's like
do it again do it again i'm like oh my
gosh come on
when it comes to your content creation
is there anything
that's off limits i don't really want to
talk about my personal
family life uh we keep it kind of
within the beauty aspect within what's
happening in our everyday
but you know we do have a series that's
coming out called tea time
and we dive into those more taboo topics
we talk about haters we talk about body
dysmorphia we talk about
depression we talk about shopping we
talk about the hatred for people when
they you know
run a red light and then blame you for
the crash i have to pivot here a little
bit
raven i have to ask you a very serious
question of course on friday we watch
the season four finale
of ravens home you're gonna get that no
not right now raven is not home
as soon as i watched that final scene i
had a gut feeling in my stomach i was
like this
feels like it could not just be a season
finale it felt like a
series finale can you tell us what the
status of raven's home is will there be
a season five
i cannot tell you the status of where it
is home because i don't know it myself
what do you hope the status of raven's
home is
do you hope to continue with it i hope
that people go back and watch
the series and write
in tweet post what they would like
because ultimately we are here for the
fans
we are here to entertain those and
do i love my cast yes do i want to work
with them for as long as i can
of course is it my decision no that's
disney channel's decision
so wait for it make noise stomp your
feet
do what you can and see what happens
are you cognizant of the way that it
ended like that people could interpret
it this way that it could be the end
i directed it so
yes i do know what it looks like i also
know there's been many series in the
history of television that have
ended but also have come back and have
ended
and not have come back so i think it's a
good cliffhanger to whatever happens
and i think that that chapter in our
life as a whole
is done and i think that we
encapsulated this series in a really
nice way and
who knows what can happen in the future
if i knew
exactly whether it's done whether it's
not i would tell you you know you're a
girl i got you but as of right now
there is no there is no set
answer for you okay i have to ask you
this just kind of fun silly question
because i believe it was demi lovato who
said that we
want to come out with like an r-rated
camp rock 3.
have you ever thought about doing an
edgier or maybe a pg-13 version
of the the brand that you've created
with that's a raven or raven's home
no because there are so many
people under the age of 18 that
need quality content if you are over the
age of 18 and need the brand
raven baxter or would like to see me
in a way you can go to youtube apm and
see what's up
but that blend itself is encapsulated
into
an age bracket that needs it and
i also know that that's not my decision
you know this is a this is a brand owned
by disney and
they know what's good for it i you know
put my input
where i can but ultimately i trust the
machine
that is the company that put me on the
map within my teenage years
what is the dream at this you know very
established place that you're at in your
career the dream for
my career is to be able to be a
successful
television um and movie director
while maintaining
a fun 8 pm channel with my wife so
when there's down time as a director
we're still creating and we're still
building
and not worrying about the right race of
being a celebrity and what i have
on and when red carpets come back i
might touch one but
probably won't be that same thrive of
you know standing next to oh my god are
you a new cover girl i'm like no i don't
want to go for that drama anymore i'm
out here with my wife enjoying time
raven you know that you are the official
as miranda pointed out
queen of the corona meme she's like the
meme of corona
she literally is the covid meme and of
course that was spurred from a
conversation that you had
with your former band mate keely
williams she was in the news last week
she's going to be part of this new
series on bet
where she and other famous singers from
the 90s and 2000s from girl groups
they're going to be moving into a house
together and they're going to try to
make music together
so i'm curious will you be tuning in
now i'm good your girl group days are
done
you're not interested in that anymore
that is
good for you keely i'm very happy for
you i'm excited that
you you know got your name back in there
that is let me tell you what that's
going to be what
that's going to be interesting that's
really interesting they've got some
girls from 702 from
cherish from danny kane i mean when when
you hear the word girl group
does that does that trigger you or does
that bring back good memories
girl group let me tell you about a girl
group especially in the
late 90s early 2000s they ruled the rush
you know i love 702
i loved uh cherish like you said i'm
even back to black
back in the day swb spice girls
and just knowing keely absolutely
interesting
since you guys had your moment of
healing on instagram was that
therapeutic for you
yeah it closed some doors it it
solidified
what i knew and you know sometimes you
know something and you just need another
little
to make sure that you're right and i was
right um
but you know what did happen which was
really cool a couple weeks ago
sat on a panel with adrian bailon on her
show
and you know he keyed it all the way up
we me and adrian have more of a
connection
of course and i know you guys have
really been ride or die
throughout the whole thing and i feel
like raven every time i see you
it's like now my obligation to ask have
you given more thought
to possibly revisiting your daytime tv
roots well it's funny you ask that
because my wife and i are
semi doing a panel like format
for t time the channel that we're
putting on youtube
we're able to talk about topics without
influences
of a daytime producer saying okay i need
you to have this point of view invited i
need you to have this
and this and this and i need you to work
like that's not there and i've been in
the industry for the past 34 years i
know what it feels like to be produced i
know what it feels like
to not really have control of your brand
because you've hired many people to help
you with it
and it's funny because we started it we
didn't ask my manager we didn't ask
anything we just started it
and everybody was like oh my goodness oh
my goodness and i'm like listen people
ask
am i going to go back on a panel people
ask what's your next adventure
and the next adventure is letting you
into
our life the way we want you into our
life you're not going to see me in a
pair of heels
and a push-up bra and a girdle like i'm
in here
no makeup no leave talking about real
topics
and that's where you're gonna see me and
i'm okay with that